in scripture we have this uh important
passage in the new testament when the
son of man comes in his glory and all
the angels with him he will sit on his
glorious throne all the nations will be
gathered before him and he will separate
people one from another as a shepherd
separates the sheep from the goats if
you put the sheep on his right hand and
the goats on his left then the king will
say to those on his right come
you who are blessed by my father take
your inheritance then he will say to
those on his left depart from me
you who are cursed into the eternal fire
prepared for the devil
and his angels so this is of course a
very famous text
the text looks
uses the symbolism of the right hand in
the left hand in a way that is very
intuitive to us and makes a lot of sense
but this symbolism is very important and
it appears universally i think in most
cultures it's related to the experience
that we have of having a hand that is
strong a hand that we can easily use and
a hand which is weak and a hand which is
more awkward it's also related to the
right and the left eye and so what i'm
going to do with you is i'm going to go
through some basic notions of what this
could mean
in terms of more than just a metaphor
but as the basic experience of how
beings coalesce towards their unity but
also break apart into multiplicity
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
so a lot of my
difficulty let's say with the symbolism
of the right and the left hand
comes about in my unders my
interpretation
of this particular image
so this image is one of the very first
images that we have i think probably the
first image that we have
of
the last judgment and so in this image
we see christ in the center
to his right we see the sheep to his
left we see the goats
to his right we also see a red angel
and to his left we see a blue angel
in his right hand is exposed and his
left hand is hidden and secret now this
is one of the first images and this
image will last
quite a long time in the
in the history of christianity
and it will become
a a kind of standard and will be
explicit in different ways
it will come all the way up to
the
iconostasis because in the iconostasis
which is this separation between the
sacred place and the nave in uh in
churches in the orthodox church very
often we will find what is known as a
deisis and the deoces will have christ
on our right let's say but also in the
day says he's often in the middle and
then on his right will be the mother of
god and then on his right again will be
this red angel which has come to be
represented as saint michael come to be
understood as saint michael and so on
his left now will be saint john the
baptist and then will be the blue angel
which we saw earlier who is has been
come to be understood as
saint gabriel the archangel gabriel this
will of course also
go all the way into the icon of the last
judgment it's very important to kind of
understand that this image of the deises
is an image of the last judgment every
time you see an image of christ in the
center with the mother of god and with
with saint john the foreigner and or
saint peter and saint paul as you can
see saint peter is here on the right and
saint paul is here on the left these
images will be
images of
we could say the last judgment or the
eschaton or the final moment where all
we can kind of see the cosmic structure
of the universe separated into two with
paradise on one side with
death and hell and breakdown and
animality on the left side
with christ in the middle
in this one i like this one very much i
keep showing the same image i'll put a
link to the this is a contemporary icon
so i'll put a link to it in the the um
in the description although although it
is really a condensation of all the old
all this all the old um
icons of the last judgment and so we see
we see christ raising his hand up we see
the sun on his right hand we see christ
with his hand going down and then we see
the moon on his left hand
so this is a moment of ascension we
could say going towards christ or going
towards heaven and this is a
something going down so it's coming down
and away from christ into death and into
hell but not just that of course these
saints that are on the left of christ
are not you know in death and hell but
we'll see how it all kind of comes
together in the symbolism as we as we
move forward
and so one of the problems that we have
is that when we look at the symbolism of
the right hand we'll find something like
opposites which seem to
be in the symbolism and so that's one of
the reasons why it's so difficult and
people will flip from one to the other
without realizing that they're doing it
they'll kind of switch from one aspect
of the symbol to the other and i think i
understand why now but it's taken me a
quite a long time to understand why and
so the four sides of this
we could say that the right hand is
concentric if you remember the words of
christ it says he says to the sheep come
into the kingdom right come toward me
enter into the kingdom and he says to
the
the goats you know move away right go
away and so what you end up seeing in
the symbolism of the right and the left
hand is you'll often find
on the right hand you'll find symbolism
of a foundation of establishing
gathering together
law of course the symbolism of the right
hand is of course the symbolism of
something which is straight
you know
in many languages the word for
right
and the word for left like in french for
example we say draw which means straight
or right hand and gauche means
awkward or you know crooked it can in
different language you'll find that the
the the right means straight and means
also
um you know
has something to do
in the sense of also a stand in for the
center or sometimes the word for right
or the notion of the right hand will
almost be like a stand in for the center
itself but then also on the right hand
if you look at you know the image of the
last judgment you find that on the right
hand you have something like mercy
protection often the right hand is
symbolized by blue or by water already
it's starting to cause problems in your
mind because that image i showed you at
the outset has the red angel on the
right hand
and on the left hand is often
represented as wild as strange as the
exception as excess
as crooked and so often it's related to
the passions
to to dissipation dilapidation all these
types of this type of images but if you
look at the the story of the last
judgment in the gospel it's also related
to rigor because christ says to those on
his left hand you know go away like he's
using a very harsh a rigorous language
he's applying the law to them very
strictly
in order to push them away
and this is will also have the symbolism
of fire
and the sword
and so what i'm going to propose to you
is that we're looking at a kind of
crossover we're looking at
at
the two sides
how depending on your point of view they
cross each other and they tend to
represent something they seem to look
like they're representing the opposite
of what
they were in the first place um and i
think that this will be very important
it seems like it's just arbitrary and
this is not a big deal but it's actually
going to be very important understanding
the relationship between myself and
others
the relationship between you know my
interaction with other people and how in
some ways
that which moves away from me is
received by the other and so there's
this switch that happens in between and
that switch is sometimes hard to
conceptualize but i think with a bit of
effort we will be able to understand it
in a way that isn't too too difficult
that it's actually pretty simple um
and this also seems to be i think what
is captured in the symbol of the
caduceus which has been brought into the
church through the symbolism of the
bishop staff which is that you have a
center you have a central
axis at the top of the axis you have a
golden ball you have something like the
source the light the sun
you know the caduceus is also
represented with wings and so it's the
idea of the spiritual
thing above you know the sun above the
source of light the source of things the
the source of being and then wrapped
around it are these two serpents which
represent two tendencies and you can see
how the serpents move
towards the center and then away from
the center towards the center and away
from the center and on one side one
serpent will move towards the center and
then we'll cross over and then we'll
move away from it and then return back
towards the center and i think that this
is actually a very important structure
it's a it's also a structure when we
look at it we it's very satisfying to us
to look at this image of a of a straight
axis and uh something moving a serpent
around it it it is um
i think it's a very primordial structure
which is why it appears in every single
culture right you know the um
the
the the europeans were probably
surprised to come to south america and
in central america and to find the image
of this serpent wrapped around a pole
with wings you know as they they
encountered the the
these empires that were in central and
south america but i think it's because
it really is one of the probably one of
the oldest symbols in a very very
universal
symbol and so as you can see
the imagery
can be represented like this like here's
an image of the last judgment from the
medieval medieval tr in the medieval
western
style that has
christ in the center
and then on the right on his right hand
he has a lily which is a representation
of mercy
and then on his left hand he has a sword
now this of course is
just a
just a just a version of this right with
the hand going up and the hand going
down you know there are different ways
to represent it
here it is the lily on the right hand
and the sword on the left hand this had
their different representation of this
they're different versions of it but
it's really important to understand how
these attributes the the lily and the
sword became
in western and also to a certain extent
in eastern art
represent you know the
the attributes of the angel the
attributes of gabriel and michael and so
here is an image of a coptic
agonist
that is again the the wall that
separates the holy place from the nave
you can see that in the econostasis
gabriel is holding a lily
and michael here is not holding a sword
but he's holding a lance
often he can also be represented holding
a sword
uh here's a close-up where you can see
gabriel holding the lily
now
once again the issue is that in in this
image you can see that it is in some
ways
the opposite of this one because at the
top you have you have christ and you
have the blue angel on his left and the
red angel on his right and this is of
course the the issue this is the problem
that we're trying to figure out and i
think that the fact that we see
the duality in the the art that
continues on until today but that often
we will see that duality flip
has to do with the very problem
of what it is that is going on in this
image so here is
a version of say michael of course
holding a sword a russian icon of saint
michael and a coptic icon of gabriel
presenting the lily to the mother of god
so if we look if we look at
the angels themselves
they are they do seem to be related to
the right and the left hand so
in the early christian times for example
in the book of enoch there is a
description of saint michael as being
the right hand of god is standing on the
right hand of god and this of course
makes sense because the name of saint
michael
means the one who is like god he who is
like god and so he is the right hand of
god he is the one who is like god
and that relates him to the right hand
i've mentioned this idea that the right
hand is something like a stand-in for
the center it's like a foundation it's
that which represents the center
below the center and so when we look at
the image of of of the mother of god on
the right hand of christ we wouldn't be
surprised to know to notice that that
image the the image of the mother god
will also be in the center for example
in the image of the ascension we will
see christ above and will see the mother
of god below st as a stand-in for the
center in the diocese we also have saint
peter who is on the right of christ and
then in the image of saint peter we have
the same notion which is that
christ says to saint peter right on you
are the stone and on this stone i will
found my church you are the foundation
of the church
and so he is in a way a stand-in for the
center being on the right hand okay
so all of these things
hopefully make sense to you
and so what why this is important is
because
we have to understand that
all identities whether it's you whether
it's a group you're participating in
anything that has a logos that is
recognized recognizes having a purpose
will have something like a right hand
and a left hand will have a concentric
element and an eccentric element and so
if you think about a uh you know think
about a a team for example or think
about let's say a company that is
building robots or i don't know building
something let's say they're building
robots
this company will have aspects
that they will deal with which will be
concentric that is aspects which will
move towards their purpose
and then they will also have access
aspects that they'd have to deal with
which will be eccentric which will be
moving away from their purpose or
further away from their purpose we could
say so we can understand that that is of
course something that you have to deal
with in your your own life there are
some things which move you towards
identity
towards let's say a kind of
strengthening of identity and there are
things which which will tend to move you
away from identity and so this is the
current we could take these kind of
cosmic currents that that that move
towards the center towards logos or the
and move away from the center logos
identity you can see that in the image
of the last judgment christ is saying it
very specifically right those on the
right hand will come near and then the
left hand will move away now in that
story it's represented just as positive
and negative in the sense that moving
towards the center is positive moving
away from the center is is negative but
that's not of course always the case as
i've often said which is that saint paul
has that imagery to him
he is the apostle to the the strangers
right the apostle to the non-jews but
everything about saint paul right how
does he convert he falls off of his
horse back off his heart he becomes
blind he
he he he talks about how he is a
shape-shifter how he is uh uh he said
that he's an aborted apostle right that
he is you know he all his imagery is
about this dissipation and this kind of
brokenness um but in his case it is not
it is not bad although there are some
bad aspects to it it is not bad on the
on the opposite side you see saint peter
who is you know the the one who speaks
up at pentecost the one who kind of
represents christ the one who is the
foundation the one who is the shepherd
for the other apostles all of this as
they kind of stand in uh for christ
and so you can see how neither one is
positive and negative but how does it
work in terms of why is it that
this the center and the left and the
right hand seem to have kind of two
opposite aspects of symbolism coming
together so i think the way that it's
represented whether it is
in the diocese whether it is the
caduceus whether it is
these different ways we try to represent
the relationship of opposites is is
it's difficult to represent visually
because in some ways you could see it
this way so this is the best way that i
understand it
so if we understand the notion of the
right hand so think about sorry this is
the right hand it sounds
it looks like left hand to in your your
experience but from the from the point
of view of the logos okay so from the
point of view of christ from the point
of view of the identity from the point
of view of center you have the right
hand which is concentric so it's moving
towards the the center and you have the
left hand which is eccentric which is
moving away from the center so the idea
would be that
the way that i experience the right hand
of the logos that i experience the right
hand of that which is facing me that
which is that i'm engaging with it could
be the logos but it could also be the
other it could also be the person that
is facing me
is i experience it as
a kind of mercy a loosening
right there's a kind of loosening of the
standards in order to bring me
closer to the center closer to
the logos
but this right hand
in myself
is a is something like
discipline it's something like
self-containment you know it's something
like holding together and so if i think
about how the right hand applies to my
relationship uh
to myself
then it is seen that it is seen as that
which establishes my identity that which
holds it together so it has a kind of
hardening to it has a kind of solidity
to it has to do with con that which
conforms conforming but if i am facing
someone else
you know or if i'm moving towards a a
purpose
then what i experience from the
moving towards that is
has to be a kind of loosening on that
bringing in a a kind of mercy at my own
fault or else there would be no way to
move into that that identity or move
into the person across from me
and i think that
on the other hand you have the same
thing because the left hand is eccentric
then
it appears in myself
as a form of dissipation so my left hand
in regards to myself is something like
awkward it's dissipation it's loosening
it's deforming
of the central identity
but if i experience the left hand from
the other for the or the left hand of
the purpose in which i'm trying to move
then it's experienced as a rigor as a
judge because
it's the hardening of that
of that identity that i'm moving towards
which is pushing me away because it's
not leaving room for me it's it's
holding me away from itself by applying
a kind of rigor and a kind of hardening
to itself and so you could see it in the
other way around again
when it's applying the right hand in
order to bring me into it it has to open
itself up it has to apply a kind of
mercy and a loosening to to move into
so that we can move towards each other
so you can understand that this is true
of course like i said of identity and
logos but it also is a reflection of the
manner in which we actually experience
the right hand and the left hand because
if i'm going to shake your hand with my
right hand i'm going to cross over
there's going to be this crossing over
which which will happen and my left hand
will be a crossover to your left hand
and so there is actually a really really
profound because it has to do with our
very experience of facing someone our
very experience of encountering a person
has to do with how these actually flip
in our in our just immediate immediate
experience but also conceptually in
terms of the way in which we let someone
come towards us or we push them away
from us
so we can understand that this
is
let's say uh
in a positive way the way that i've
represented it
but we can also see it
right as let's say
flipped in terms of the way that i
represented it up here
means
i have the positive side you could say
but i also have the negative side here
and usually that's what it is usually
the right hand is something like
positive and the left hand is tends to
be something like negative not always
but it often is that
and so now we can understand how
if i am in myself
my right hand that is my tendency
towards my own center my capacity to to
be in myself and to to move towards
myself can be experienced as pride as
self-sufficiency
whereas
in a more positive way on the other side
on the left side you can understand that
my the left hand in regards to myself
can be seen as a kind of exteriorization
a possibility of of glory even you could
say that is something which is not
just in my center which is kind of
emanating or moving out or or let's say
overflowing from me can be seen as the
as this left hand and so you know when
we say things in the church
when people say things like how you know
the fire of hell is the fire of
pentecost you can kind of understand it
now like why that would be why is it
that the
the fire of hell as this kind of burning
will be experienced by those
who are let's say will experienced by
those in a certain condition as the
rigor and hardening of god but that for
others will be experienced as a kind of
glory as a kind of expansion of their of
their being depending on their
disposition depending on how they are
related to relating to the the logos we
could say so you can see that it's not a
system it's really important because if
you try to see it completely as a system
then you're going to it's more like a
poem it's more like a it's more like
rhyming it has this
it has an intuition of structure but the
structure always kind of eludes you
because
because it is
i think it really is very very basic in
terms of our experience
and so this is where we can kind of
understand saint peter and saint paul
more
easily and the relationship between what
we call the daisies so now again this is
the this is a daisies with christ in the
center with the mother of god on his
right hand with the with uh saint john
the foreigner on his left hand and john
the baptist with saint peter on his
right hand with saint paul on his left
hand
and so we can see now the different
symbolism so in the in the case of the
mother of god we have this
containing we have this gathering in we
have also this idea of a kind of
standing for the center
in the relationship of heaven and earth
all of this is so she is gathered into
the center and in in some ways she's
also hidden because of that she she has
a a uh she is also seen as the one who
provides mercy provides you know a kind
of softness
to us
so all of this kind of symbolism comes
together if we can understand the
different aspects of it
and then saint peter
he appears also in a way as a stand-in
for the center as a boldness towards the
center
um as a kind of uh representative again
as being the shepherd the one who is a
stand-in for christ in the world
and now on the left hand then we have
saint john the foreigner who is out in
the wilderness he is wearing animal
skins if you remember the image of in
the last judgment where you see all
these animals on the left side he's
wearing animal skins he's yelling he's
making a lot of noise he's telling
people to repent
and so there's nothing secret about him
it's all outside it's all this kind of
outer aspect and now the same again with
saint paul who is like i said he's a
roman citizen so he's almost a stranger
he is a shape-shifter he says he's all
things to all people
so much about saint paul is about this
if you're going to understand it you can
kind of see
why it is that saint paul represents
himself with all these types of
characteristics he even he says right
that he's a that he is a an aborted
apostle
um that's a pretty strong statement in
terms of the idea of something which is
rejected and and dead and uh you know
and and is kind of far away
but at the same time we can see how
one leads to the other you know one side
leads to the other and so think about
saint peter and think about how saint
peter
is
his symbolism is always the same right
his symbolism is always the one who is
bold but then because of his boldness
sinks
right the one who moves in a way from
the right hand to the left hand so
because of his boldness he he walks out
on the water then he sinks he tells he
tells christ that he will never betray
him and and then he does he tells christ
that that christ doesn't have to die
right he's like no you don't have to die
you can contain yourself you can just be
the center in the sense of the right
hand and the establishment and the and
the uh
the solidity but christ says to saint
peter get behind me satan get behind me
you oppose her so you can understand how
this symbolism of moving from the right
to the left and how let's say the one at
the top is the kind of the opposite at
the bottom
is happening in the symbolism of these
two people and you can so you can see
that the
the sin of saint peter is something like
pride
and so in saint paul you have the the
one who falls off the
who falls off the uh the the horse
who does all that and his
first sin
is something like the thorn in the flesh
you know and uh
he it seems to be some kind of sensual
sin related of course to a woman because
this idea of the thorn is the
consequence of the fall then also a
thorn in his side which is related to
the idea of eve coming from his side so
he has this whole idea of
of what it is that his sin is which
seems to have something to do with
sexuality uh though it's not totally
clear um but then also
people are getting mad about this but
there's also saint paul has the kind of
opposite sin or i don't know if it's a
sin but it's a tendency which that which
that saint paul is always
boasting he's always boasting without
boasting he's always saying you know he
he he has a very strange behavior in the
in his letters where he's always saying
uh you know
he's boasting about he says on the one
hand that he is nothing that he's all
these things but then he kind of
secretly boasts as he's doing that so
that seems to also be part of this
crossover that we find in the right and
the left hand uh symbolism
and so now we can understand there's a
citation from saint gregory from saint
maximus the confessor that i'm always
quoting but i'm going to quote it to you
again because i think it's a very
powerful grasping of what the right and
the left hand are
in terms of the negative part of it so
say maximus talks about the demons that
combat us by the lack of virtue
are those that teach us prostitution and
drunkenness greed and jealousy
so we can see that these these sins
right they are
the sins of dissipation the sins of
dilapidation
the sins of passion in the strict sense
right of of becoming a slave to
something outside of you that that
dominates over you
and then he says the demons that combat
us by excess of virtue are those that
teach us presumption vainglory and pride
and who by the vices of the right
secretly place in us the vices of the
left so here you can actually see this
crossover which is that that which
begins in pride ends in dissipation and
dilapidation and we can see that this is
something which is true in the story of
saint peter who starts with pride
he starts with boldness and then ends
sinking in the water sinking in the mire
he ends denouncing uh christ of course
he ultimately repents but we can
understand the pattern that say maximus
isn't taking this from
he's not just pulling it out of his hat
he has such a deep intuition of
scriptural symbolism and the scriptural
images that he's able to to show
um
to show it in our everyday experience
and so
this also seems to be suggested in the
image of the transfiguration
so in this image of the transfiguration
i like this one particularly because you
can see
on the right of christ you have christ
going up the mountain and then on the
left of christ you have christ going
down the mountain so this this movement
of moving towards the top and moving
away from the top is there in this
version of it it's not always there but
in this version it is and then you see
on the right hand of christ you have
elijah now elijah is
interesting because elijah
you know is the one who calls down the
fire of god he's the one who mocks the
false gods he is
you know and even the way he looks he
has that wild kind of saint john the
baptist
aspect to him but look at he's on the
right side
of christ and then on the left side we
have moses who is the one who brings the
law
who is the one who who
brings the revelation but who also
his sin his the same sin is saint peter
right the sin of moses was to think that
he was the one who would bring the water
to the israelites and so you can see
that saint said moses kind of up here is
related to peter down here also because
moses is a
is the stand-in for
god in the text i mean god says crazy
things in exodus he says
he says you know uh
like i'm setting you up as my you know
as my servant and then you will be god
to aaron and then aaron will be your
your your servant you know towards the
people so he's kind of setting moses as
a little god in the world who who acts
on the others and so he is the stand-in
for god in the story
um
and then if you look at the bottom now
it flips so moses is here
saint peter is here
and interestingly enough saint peter is
looking towards the center right so he
is
looking towards the middle
but then on the left hand
you have james
who is falling over backwards
kind of like saint paul on the on the
donkey uh and he is facing
elijah here who elijah interestingly
enough you know goes up in a flaming
chariot and so in this case you can see
how the flame and the chariot and the
flame and the glory and the chariot as
well because the chariot is a is a
added
aspect right it is a supplement a
chariot is like a vehicle which is added
to
the identity it's like a body and so he
goes up in this chariot this flaming
chariot going up into heaven and so it's
very much in some ways an image
of all that is on the left hand but here
he is represented on the right and i
think it really is to represent this
crossing over that happens between the
left and the right hand depending on
your perspective and like i said it's
not a system it really is a kind of
intuitive thing
that happened in the in the tradition so
ultimately i wanted we come back to this
just basic image of the yin yang symbol
which i think is probably actually in
terms of a geometric representation
might be one of the best representations
of how the two two opposites come
together how one opposite drives the
manifestation of the other
uh in this way and so it really is a
a powerful image
to help us understand what it is that
these two streams we could say of
reality how they come together and how
they work and like i said it's really
important to understand that
that this is not just like abstract of
course can help us understand the art
and it can help us understand the
stories but it is something which exists
at every level of our experience it is
something you know this
tendency towards
identity and towards solidity toward the
center and this tendency tendency
towards dissipation and breakdown and
multiplicity is something which is part
of every identity we can recognize and
it's important to be able to see how
let's say one causes the other in a
positive way and also how the excess of
one causes can cause also the excess of
the other in a more negative way
and how they are related together of
course there would be much more to say
and much more to meditate on but i
thought this would at least be
a basic uh
a basic introduction to the symbolism
and remembering that this symbolism is
not of course just in the images i
showed you it is there all through the
old testament as well it appears as
i think even right at the outset as the
idea of the fruit of good and evil this
basic opposition and then it appears as
the column of fire and water in exodus
it appears as the two pillars of the
temple yakin and boaz if you look at
those two pillars you can see that yakin
means to establish you know to to
no it means to establish so it is the
right hand really and then boaz is of
course the uh
the one who married ruth who is this the
one who went towards the stranger and
has something to do with the left hand
in this kind of exteriorization and
interestingly enough it's funny to
notice that
in the christian in the in the jewish
tradition if you look at the names of
the of the the
the
the angels they do tend michael tends to
be related to something more like
mercy and the right hand
and gabriel seems to be related to
gebura or the idea of of more rigor and
more strength you could say an exterior
sticker exteriorization of strength um
whereas in christianity it seems to
actually flip but it has to do with this
facing each other i think think that
when you look if you think of
christianity and judaism kind of facing
and shove each other and exchanging
their position you could say
at least in the way that saint paul
presents it as you know the idea of the
uh those that were under rigor are now
under grace and and and vice versa this
is the way that saint paul presents it
in his in his text there seems to be
this happening in even the image images
of saint michael which for now for us
say michael
starts to be represented as red as the
sword as all of this all of this while
nonetheless also being related sometimes
to the right hand and this crossover and
then gabriel being re
represented rather as mercy as the lily
as the blue angel and but then
nonetheless also being on the left hand
and so there's a definitely a mystery
there i of course invite all of you to
continue to think about this with me
because i've i feel like i've definitely
not exhausted all the symbolism you can
also look up some articles that i wrote
for the orthodox arts journal about 10
years ago on different right and
left-hand symbolisms there's of course
different aspects to that some have to
do with authority and power you know and
and there are also other aspects that
i've treated in those articles so i'll
put those in the description that you
can look up so thanks for thinking about
this with me and this difficult but
important symbolism and i will talk to
you very soon
[Music]
you